[APPLAUSE]
CHEN LIENG: Hello everyone.
How's it going?
I hope you all had a great
GDC experiences today.
And welcome to Firebase where
we talk about mobile gaming
experiences and how we can
make it better for you.
Hi, I'm Chen.
I'm the iOS tech lead--
sorry.
I think I don't have the click.
There you go.
Hi, I'm Chen.
I'm the iOS tech lead for
Firebase Cloud Messaging.
I'm here today with two of
my Google colleague, Patrick
and Sumit.
PATRICK MARTIN: So yeah,
my name's Patrick Martin.
I'm a developer advocate based
out of Boulder, Colorado.
I actually have a degree
in game development.
And I've spent the last decade
or so building mobile games
and ultrarobotic toys.
SUMIT CHANDEL: And
I'm Sumit Chandel.
I've spent a number of years
at Google Developer advocating
a lot of different products,
including Google Web
Toolkit, AdWords API, Android
Wear, and most recently,
Firebase.
So we're pretty excited
about sharing with you
how Firebase can help within
your game development.
And with that, I'll
throw it back to Chen.
CHEN LIENG: Awesome.
Thank you, guys.
So there's three
parts of the talk.
First, we're going to give
an overview about Firebase
along with some of
the latest updates.
And then I'm going to
invite Patrick back
on stage to show you how to
view the game with Firebase
and Cloud services.
Patrick's going to cover some
of the new features coming up
this year.
So it's going to be a
great technical overview.
And then we're going to bring
Sumit back on stage to show you
how to grow your users.
Driving player engagement is a
critical part of the business.
So stay tuned for that.
So what is Firebase?
On a higher level,
Firebase is Google Cloud's
specialized mobile and web
app development platform.
Let me give you a little
bit of background.
If you come here to any of
the Google Cloud talk today,
you probably already know
that the Google Cloud
is a powerful tool.
It is built on cutting-edge
technologies in both hardware
and software infrastructure.
It is also platform agnostic
because no matter what
platform your games are
at, GCP can support it.
It can be your
backbone because you
remove the burden of
provisioning and managing
your own server.
And it provides a variety of
tools to help you to scale.
So tools like App Engine, Cloud
Storage, BigQuery, TensorFlow
and many, many other tools.
It's very powerful.
And it provides a reliable
and secure connection
so you can safely deploy
your code to the cloud.
So what is Firebase?
Firebase is built
on top of the GCP.
And it is specialized in
mobile and web applications.
So if you're building a
mobile game or web app,
Firebase is more tailored
to your experiences
because we focus on many of the
common problems, engineering
problems that mobile
developers facing.
And also we provide custom
APIs so your app can easily
communicate with the GCP,
the Google Cloud Platform.
So in a way that would
provide quicker path to get
you started on GCP.
So here's a subset of
the Firebase products
that we are going talk
to you about today.
As you can see, Firebase
deliver solutions
throughout the entire lifecycle,
from building a game, improve
the quality, to
engage more users,
and driving player retention.
And no matter what
you team size is,
it could be one person startup
or enterprise-level companies,
we have tools that can
support any use cases.
And our products also focus on
many aspects of the business.
If you're engineer-- engineer
like to focus on problem like,
how do I do this
more efficiently?
Or how do I scale?
So we have tools like that.
So, for example, if you're
sending push notifications,
we have Cloud Messaging.
And then if you want
to do [INAUDIBLE] flow,
we have authentication.
Or if you wonder, how do I build
a serverless infrastructure,
we have GCP tools like
Cloud Storage and Firestore.
And these are the
critical components
of building a game app.
And that's why the
engineers was focused on.
And Firebase provide
tools so that you can--
help you to save--
and save the cost.
And it also help you
to build infrastructure
so you don't have to do that.
If you're a product
manager, you wonder,
how does my game perform?
You want to understand
your users better.
So we have tools
like that as well,
like Analytics, A/B
testing, or BigQuery.
A lot of our products can
export BigQuery easily
so you can do deep
analysis on GCP.
And you can also run experiments
to understand your users better
while making the
product decisions.
And lastly, if you
have QA team, we've
got great tools there to cover
like any aspects of improving
your apps quality, like
Crashlytics, Performance,
and Test Lab.
Later in the session,
Sumit and Patrick
will do a deep dive on
some of the use case
to show how exactly
you can do this.
And what's best about
Firebase and GCP
is that they work well together.
Under the hood, they have the
same project and same billing
account.
So it's very easy
for you to manage.
And if you're a
Cloud customer, you
can import your project
to Firebase instantly.
And many of our
Firebase products
are already running on GCP, such
as Cloud Storage, Firestore,
and Cloud Functions, so
anything with a cloud.
So say you're a first-time user.
What do you get outside
this Firebase package?
Let me help you to viralize it.
So first you get
Firebase console.
It serves as a
developer control panel.
It's where you set
up a new project.
And you can configure and
monitor your Firebase services.
And then you get a bunch of SDK.
You pick and choose
the one you need.
You install in your game.
And you run a bunch of code to
quickly enable functionalities.
And the client will
make secure connections
to the Firebase service on
the Cloud and to this console.
So it will all sync up together.
And the best part is
you don't have to build
any of the infrastructure.
And it is secure.
It's scalable.
Oh, and one more thing.
Firebase, the console
is also great tool
for your game designers
or marketing people
if they want like monitor
data or added game contents.
And we'll provide
a variety of SDKs.
For Android developers
here, the game developer,
we have SuperPass and
Unity cross-platform SDKs.
And if you are iOS and
Android developer like me,
we have that as well.
And lastly, our web SDKs
supports both mobile and web
applications.
Firebase was
launched since 2016.
And over three years, we've
seen tremendous growth.
To this day, we have over 1.5
million monthly active apps.
And developers choosing
us because, A, Firebase
is easy to use, it's powered
by Google Cloud technology,
and integrates well with many
cross-platform and third-party
tools.
Now I have some new
updates for you.
If you're a Unity developer,
now the onboarding flow
has become easier for you.
Previously, when you set up a
Unity cross-platform project,
you had to set it up twice.
You had to go to
the iOS platform,
set it up, and do
it again on Android.
Now we get this
shiny Unity button.
If you click on it,
now it can set up
both your iOS and Android
app at the same time
and download the
configuration files and import
to your project and finish
with downloading the Unity SDK.
Again, it's quick and easy.
Lastly, I want to talk
a bit about open source.
At Firebase, we really value
the transparency of our SDK.
We understand that it is
important for the developers
to know the exact behavior
of our source code,
especially when it comes to
how we handle the user privacy
and data, which is why we're
excited that our C++ SDK is
also open source now.
Now if you're a C++ developer,
you can choose to integrate one
of our open-source SDK.
With the source
code accessible, it
provides great flexibility
in your development flow.
First, you can audit
your source code
and make modifications
at your own pace.
And the Firebase
open-source community
has continued to
grow over the years.
And more and more SDKs
from different platform
had been open source.
And now you can help contribute
back to the community.
You can be part of it.
First, you can help port the
SDK to a different platform
that we don't support.
Or you can help
making contribution
to the existing SDK by adding
new features or fixing issues.
Now I'm sure you all
got excited about using
Firebase in your games.
I'm going to pass that to
Patrick to talk about it.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK MARTIN: Hi, everybody.
Thanks, Chen, for
that introduction.
And what I want
to talk to you now
is how to build-- what it's like
to build a game in Firebase.
And I think what
will make this easier
for everyone to understand
is if I first gave you
guys a little bit of background
from where I'm coming from.
So for the past
couple of years, I've
been doing a lot of research
and development and prototyping.
And it was the
kind of thing where
I'd have a few
days, maybe a week,
to throw a whole bunch
of stuff together, get
a concept off the ground,
and get it testable.
And I didn't need that test
to live past the meeting where
it got approved or something.
So I used a very different
stack than I did back
when I worked on asynchronous
multiplayer games.
If you ever work on
something like that,
you need your servers to be
accessible all the time, 24/7,
and for any play length.
And the tools to achieve
each one of these
are typically completely
different sets.
You'll normally rip everything
up from your prototyping
and do something brand
new in production.
And I would say
that, yes, there go!
The job of every developer,
every game developer,
is really to find the fun.
Whether you're in preproduction,
post-production, or working
on a game, your users
aren't paying you
for just pretty
graphics or cool tech.
It's something fun
that they can enjoy.
And Firebase, I think,
helps shorten the distance
from any idea you have in your
head to being able to actually
experiment and iterate on it.
And not only is this then backed
by Google's Cloud Platform,
as Chen mentioned, but
if for whatever reason
Firebase doesn't meet your
needs once you scale up
from prototyping
to production, you
do have the full brute force
of Google's Cloud behind you.
And you can work
directly there if that's
where your needs take you.
So I want to show you what it's
like building a game really
quickly using actually a
single player game called
MechaHamster, which is our--
it's our testing project for
Firebase's Unity integration.
So MechaHamster
is really simple.
It's like one of those old,
wooden marble maze games.
You just tilt your phone
and get Hammy the hamster
to the end of this maze up here.
Yeah.
Pretty simple.
I'm sure you guys all get it.
And what I'm going to do is
enhance this single player game
by giving it a Cloud
backend with secure
and shared data in
it that I probably
wouldn't want to risk otherwise
if I didn't have something
like Firebase to host it on.
So the way we decided to
start expanding this game
was to build our
own level editor.
The basic idea behind it
is that normally a designer
would have to go through
the entire dev stack
to get a build onto
a phone to test it,
which could sometimes
take minutes.
And then other people
wouldn't necessarily
get to play unless you
walked over to their desk
or you pulled it down
from a build server.
So we really wanted
to build something
that it could work on the phone,
press play, test it instantly,
and just share it
out to the whole team
really quickly, like at
the press of a button.
And since these levels
are just like a 2D grid,
it's a very easy thing
to serialize, store,
and interact with.
So we decided to use
Firebase's real-time database.
This represents all of
the data in your database.
It is effectively, a
very large JSON document,
which I know some people love
JSON, some people hate it.
The point isn't that
you're writing JSON
but that many languages and
game engines, like Unity,
can serialize to and from it
just as a library function.
So we just hit a node
with the JSON serializer,
get all the data
out into a database.
And I want to focus
on the real-time bit
just a little bit.
This isn't real-time
like 30 frames
a second, like a video game.
But this is real-time enough
that you could do something
like Google Docs,
collaborative editing.
I find that sometimes I can
even type on one computer
and look at another
and kind of know
what I'm doing in a Google Doc.
You could do the same
sort of synchronization
in a level editor if you
built out the UI for it.
But the other really cool
thing a real-time database does
for you is cache everything.
So if you're offline, if you'd
like drove through a tunnel
while you're working
on a level, all
your writes are still
instant to the database.
So you can use the database
provided in our SDK.
It's kind of your
single source of truth.
And then whenever
you go back online,
your local copy doesn't
get stomped with the web.
And the web copy doesn't get
stomped with your local copy.
We just replay the transactions
you made while you're offline,
which is kind of a nice way
to protect against data loss
as you're doing
these migrations.
It's kind of a hard
problem if you've ever had
to implement this on your own.
And a cool thing that
came out of all this work
to build a level editor is a--
well, we're all game
developers, right?
We're at the Game
Developer Conference.
And I'm sure we all had
that moment when we realized
that games are not
magical plastic disks that
appeared in like a game store
or, in my case, cartridges.
For me, the moment
that I realized this
was when I found the
Quake 1 level editor.
And I started making,
actually, really
bad maps where only I knew
the cool weapon drops or like
sniping positions or something.
So why couldn't we enable
fans of MechaHamster
to express their
creativity like that
and maybe join us in
the creative process?
And even though we're storing
this data in the Cloud,
we're able to confidently
enable this kind of curated user
sharing with this
rules language that we
have with Realtime Database.
This is just a JSON object
with annotations that
lay parallel to your database.
And they're relatively simple.
I I've actually
simplified this a bit
more just so it
fits on the slide.
But here we just saying
the node map list
is readable by the
entire internet.
But by changing this to the
string off not equals to null,
we guarantee that any user
trying to read this map list
will only get it if
they are logged in.
And these statements
you put here
can be JavaScript expressions.
So you can enforce rules like,
only the creator of a map
can use it until they market
it as shared, stuff like that.
And where that auth
came from is actually
from Firebase authentication.
In MechaHamster, we opted to
use email address and password
account management
as well as something
called anonymous sign on.
Anonymous sign on in
particular might sound weird.
But all it's doing is
associating your device
with the account instead of
like a username and password.
And later on, if the user
wants to share their data
between devices,
they can migrate up
to an email address account.
And you can, of course, opt out
of signing in if you just don't
want these online features.
And I should stress that
this email address password
authentication isn't me
being silly and thinking
I can implement my own sign
in logic with all the security
issues associated with this.
This is a Firebase product and
has all of Google's security
guarantees.
But we also support all these
other authentication providers.
Now if you're prototyping,
and you're just
trying to get an idea of the
ground as fast as you can,
use email address and password.
But all you have to do is
integrate the client SDKs
for each one of
these auth providers.
We do everything else
in the cloud for you,
validating the user token.
We even let you merge
and migrate accounts.
So GameCenter on iOS
is a new integration.
If you added it to your app,
you could allow your users
to add that to their account.
And all of a sudden,
they have a new way
of signing on that doesn't
require them to start again
from scratch.
So another thing we wanted
to do is add leaderboards
to MechaHamster.
This is super-common in games.
And it's so common that we
just made it open-source.
So it can go up here,
grab the source code
for a sample
leaderboard integration,
actually start playing with
the Realtime Database right
now in your existing game
writing just a minimal amount
of code, get your feet
wet, decide whether or not
it's right for you.
So that's at Firebase Extended
slash Unity solutions.
So we wanted to augment
our leaderboard though
with user replays.
Now for reasons that might
become apparent later
in my talk, we had replay
recording in MechaHamster.
So we decided we'd
show how people got--
oh, there we go.
Yeah.
We wanted to show how people got
the high scores that they had.
And you might just
think, hey, I'm
going to use JSON
serializer and Unity
and just dump whatever
data structure
I have for the replays
into the Realtime Database.
But it turns out even
compressed in a flat buffer,
these replays are around
30 to 60 kilobytes.
And at some point, the
RealTime is not real time
just because you're
passing a lot of data.
And also you don't want to
collaboratively edit replays.
To me, that sounds more like
cheating than a feature.
So we needed somewhere
large [INAUDIBLE]
to store this replay data.
And we decided to use
Cloud Storage for Firebase.
Now this is another database.
It's a key value storage where
the key is just any path.
So logically order
this however you want.
And the value is
really anything you
want to put up
there, videos, player
avatars, in our case, replays.
And the flow for
uploading a high score now
becomes you add the high
score to the high score table.
There's an extra node there
for-- the replay will live.
You start asynchronously
uploading the replay data,
get a callback when
that completes,
and you can just update
the note in the leaderboard
to point to your replay.
There is one problem
with this, though.
Now that we have
two databases, when
a high score is no
longer a high score,
the replay data will leak.
So we use something called
Cloud Functions to listen
for when there's a change,
in this case, a Create
event in the Realtime Database.
When that happens, we check
how many high scores there
are for the map you're
on, knock off the lowest
if there are more than five, and
cleanup the associated replay
data.
So Cloud Functions are
actually a really awesome tool
for someone like me who's lived
mostly in the client space.
They're just now out
of beta for Firebase.
And they let you run
mobile back end code
without managing the servers.
Again, if I'm prototyping,
this is an awesome shortcut
to get to where we need to be.
And it is still on Google's
Cloud infrastructure.
So these are reliable
and scalable.
You write these in
JavaScript or TypeScript.
And you have the full MPM
package manager to deal with.
So you can really go crazy here.
They are still secure, so
Firebase authentication still
applies.
Auth not equals to
null is a valid way
to check if a user's log in.
And the user is guaranteed
to not be spoofing their user
token or something by now.
And these let you
not only communicate
between different
Firebase products
but also between
Firebase and the web.
So just some examples of
what you might use these
for in games, if you have like
asynchronous multiplayer board
games, rather than just
trusting players to not
claim that they roll
nat 20s all the time,
they're the Gandalf of
monopoly or something,
you can push your die rolls
off into a Cloud Function.
If you have a gacha
mechanic in your game,
you can use the Cloud
Function to make sure
they have enough
capsules or whatever,
subtract one, roll the loop.
But if you're using something
like Crashlytics from Firebase,
you can actually listen for a
new crash to happen in the wild
and actually automatically
file a Jira for your team.
Maybe if a crash
spikes an occurrence,
you send a message to the SOS
channel on your team's Slack,
and everyone starts
rallying around it.
So now it's time to ship a game.
And the thing that keeps me up
at night, whenever I hit go,
is when the inevitable
review comes
in that says, game is a
blank screen on launch
or it crashes on launch.
It worked in all our
devices in the QA test lab.
But there's just something
in the wild we kind
of take account of.
So you really need to run
your game on actual hardware.
You need to test various OS
and hardware combinations
because even if you're using
test-driven development,
something like you're using
a feature in a shader that's
not supported will still cause
a shader compilation error.
Actually once had a game
as blank screen on launch
because the OpenGL context
claimed that it supported
a level of antialiasing
that it actually didn't.
And it just failed to
create my context for me.
And you really want
these to be automatic,
like not just a
human going through.
You want to be able to
shove these up to a server
where some cadence built into
like your build pipeline and be
able to know the very
moment a build fails.
So for MechaHamster,
we're using Robo tests
in Firebase Test Lab.
Now MechaHamster didn't
have many unit tests.
And at least, in my
experience in the industry,
that is really common
in video games.
But with Robo tests, we can
just upload the production APK
and-- well, the way
I like to imagine
it is a friendly
little robot walks
into your game, kind of
stares at your view hierarchy,
and then presses all the
buttons as fast as it possibly
can until it crashes
or it times out.
And this will run
on real hardware.
There's literally like
racks of phones or something
in a data center somewhere.
And what's really
cool about this,
especially for the
kind of test it does,
it might be hard
for me to reproduce.
I might C&R the bug
just because like it
required tapping in a specific
spot in the splash screen
or something.
So it records the
video, shows you
little circles of where
this robot was interacting.
You get the stack
trace if it crashed.
You get the log of everything
that happened leading up to it.
And you know that this ran on
kind of a clean environment.
There's not like
that weird app that
kills applications in the
background to theoretically
save battery life or something.
This is just a stock device
that you're running this on.
But some engineers
in the room might
have noticed that I said this
robot walks around and looks
at your view hierarchy.
And we're game developers.
Our view hierarchy is
probably just a GL Context.
So this seems kind of useless.
So, of course, we decided
to use our AI Chops
to create something that we
call AI assisted monkey testing.
This uses machine vision to
look at the output of your game
like a human, find things that
look interactable, usually
buttons, and concentrate the
random presses at these buttons
so you don't have to expose
your custom UI to Robo test
or, in this case, AI
system monkey testing
to get a useful test.
As you see here the AI
assisted monkey testing video
is already to the logical
end of this unit test,
whereas the Robo test
is still clicking around
in some corner of
the screen somewhere.
If anything else, this is just a
safety net for your existing QA
team.
You don't have to do any
additional integration or APK.
This is running
on actual hardware
in a data center,
as I pointed out,
or on virtual devices if you
want to test like weird OS
or screen combinations.
And, yeah!
It's pretty cool.
Had another bullet
point, but, yeah.
I already went over it.
So there's another
kind of unit testing
though that we usually call it
like demo loops or a profiling
test.
In Firebase Test Lab,
we call it game loops.
And the general idea
of this is that you
know what parts of the
game you need to hammer,
how to implode all
the shaders, get
a bunch of geometry on screen.
And not only do you want to
see if phones will run it
without crashing,
but you might also
want to profile this and make
sure you're hitting your min
frame rate targets
on all your devices
and kind of build up a list of
which devices you need a lower
performance profile
on or something.
So once again, you upload your
production APK to the cloud,
run it on real devices that
span the range of low end
to like flagship phones.
And the way this works in a
production environment is it
sends something called
an intent, which,
if you're not familiar
with native Android Dev,
you're just coming from
the Unity background,
this is basically a command line
argument but to an Android app.
And I've spent a lot
of time in Unity.
I wasn't quite sure
how I'd get this in.
So when I looked
at MechaHamster,
I found this Game
Loop manager class.
I'm not sure where it came from.
It's actually from
this code lab.
It's very easy to follow.
If you already profile
or use demo loops,
I'd recommend--
walk through this.
And you just instantly
grow your QA test pool
for this sort of thing.
Again, even if you
don't want to do this,
if you want to put the
minimum amount of effort
possible into testing--
I'm not saying that's a
bad thing, but sometimes
it's the reality--
just upload your APK now.
And you just gave your QA an
extra little bit of safety net
as they go through the
normal approval process.
So you're still going to
have crashes in the field.
You can't catch everything.
Again, there's like
that crazy app that
kills games in the background
and people root their phones
and all this other stuff.
You're still going to
need crash reporting.
And Crashlytics is kind
of a really neat way
to gather crashes from
the field and sort them
by frequency, device type,
OS version, everything
you need to--
stack traces as
well-- everything
you need to not
only figure out why
a crash happened but see if it's
something you need to address.
Because the reality is
that some phones will just
have a marginal market share.
And if he cannot reliably fix
the crash in a short amount
of time, if this phone is
a fraction of a percent
of your market, it may be more
fiscally pertinent to just
blacklist it on the Play store.
But if when the brand new
flagship phone comes out,
and your game is crashing
all the time on it--
this actually happened to
me when the first multicore
phones came out--
if you have that Cloud
Functions hook running,
you might get a spike
in the SOS channel,
this bug is happening
a whole lot.
And you can rally
your team around,
make sure you get
that preorder in,
and start testing on the new
phone if that happens to you.
And Crashlytics is now
integrated with Unity,
which is really awesome to me.
Again, in the past, what would
happen is I'd get like the C++
stack trays, and I'd have to
bring that into the IL2CPP
output, and then try to figure
out what C# generated that,
which was kind of a process.
There are helpful guides for it.
But it took me a
little bit of time.
In this case, I
accidentally cleared a field
in a game object.
And I got a stack trace.
And Crashlytics,
almost instantly,
I was refreshing
the dashboard that
showed me exactly where
to look to find this.
And in this case,
this isn't even a bug
I would have made
it as a programmer.
Or I could have made
it as a programmer,
but also a designer or an
artist might have made this.
Or it could have just
happened from version control.
So Crashlytics, is pretty
much a free integration
if you're already
using Firebase.
So you might as well
just drop it in, again,
for a little bit
of extra safety net
just to bump the quality of
your app up a little higher.
With that, I'm going to
hand this over to Sumit
to talk to you about growth.
[APPLAUSE]
SUMIT CHANDEL: All right, y'all.
So we built the game.
We shipped the game.
And now it's time
to grow the game.
Now when you grow
your game, there's
the traditional marketing
methods and teams
that your company
or startup might
be using where
they run a campaign
and try to grow your
player or user base.
And there's a lot of different
tools and innovations
available to those teams there.
And that's probably something
you want to continue to use.
That, however, is
different than what
I wanted to talk about
here in the context
of Firebase developer
services and Google Cloud.
So within the developer context,
what you want to be able to do
is easily A/B test new features.
So you've shipped your game.
You know where you're at now.
And you want to figure out
as you release new features,
are they good or bad?
How are they going
to be received?
And certainly, you
don't want to damage
what you've already released.
So you want to be able to easily
A/B test and then furthermore,
measure the results
of those A/B tests
as well to determine
their effectiveness.
Personally, I'm
still A/B testing
whether Gregory's
Coffee, Starbucks Coffee,
or Third Rail Coffee makes me
more productive in the morning.
Results so far, inconclusive.
All right.
So I'll set the stage with this
question or this opening use
case of, how can I track
how my game is doing now?
And how can it easily
test new features
and see if those are good?
So we'll look at the first
part of this question first,
which is, how can I track
how my game is doing now?
OK, so to track how
your game is doing,
you've got to look at data.
And depending on the type
of game that you have
and the number of
players, we could
be talking about a lot of data.
So take, for example,
a massively multiplayer
online RBG game
where you're not just
logging single events of
users tapping on your screen
or interacting with your game as
single events that are getting
recorded, but you're
collecting a stream of events
over a long interval of
time, maybe a few hours.
In that kind of game, a
player might be interacting
with other players in the game.
And you're logging that.
They might be buying,
selling, or trading items.
And you're logging those.
They might be completing quests
or accepting new missions
or taking a certain
direction on your map.
And these are all events
that you're collecting
over hours for one player.
Now imagine if you've
got thousands or millions
of players.
That's a lot of data
that you're collecting.
So hence, the image
of this data center
to represent a
whole lot of data,
for example, on one of Google
services that relies on this.
So that's where Google
Cloud BigQuery can come in.
So if you're a
large game publisher
and you've already collected
a lot of player data,
Google Cloud BigQuery has
a free bulk loading tool
where you can upload all
of that data into BigQuery
and then start
slicing and dicing it
using SQL-like queries with the
computational power behind them
to actually return the results.
So you can start establishing
a view of what your players are
doing in your game.
A couple of quick things
to note about BigQuery
is that, one, it's
fully managed and server
and, second, storage and compute
are independent from each other
and can scale up or
scale down and on demand.
So that kind of flexibility can
save a lot of business costs
from your side because you
don't have to invest upfront
in building your own
infrastructure for logging
or storage pipelines to
manage all this data.
And, of course, storing
that amount of data
is already a pain let
alone analyzing it
to figure out what's going on.
But maybe you're
not ready to invest
a lot of logging
infrastructure in the game
as you just released it.
Maybe you just want
to release your game
and start getting
some kind of analytics
without having to invest in
that logging or storage pipeline
infrastructure.
So for such a situation,
you can use something
like Google Analytics
for Firebase.
The way it works is pretty much
as soon as you add the Firebase
SDK to your project,
you're going
to start getting out of the box
events automatically reported.
And when you log into
your Firebase console,
you're going to see these
reports automatically being
generated for your game.
So that includes things like
in-app purchase revenue, user
engagement, retention, daily
active users, and so forth.
But more importantly,
Analytics also
allows you to use custom events
that you can log in your game
as well.
So those are things that are
more specific and interesting
for your game.
For MechaHamster, this
might be things like,
did anyone use the map editor?
Did someone create a map?
How many times did they retry
a level before they gave up?
Did they even manage
to finish the level?
Which levels did they select?
These kind of things
are custom events
that you might want to
record or that we'd want
to record for MechaHamster.
And you can also choose
that for your own games
and have it available in
the Analytics dashboard.
And then while we're talking
about creating these custom
events, you'll want to mark some
of these as conversion events
as well.
And you can do so in
the Firebase console
by hitting those toggles--
one second, I'm trying to
click the thing, OK, sorry--
by hitting those toggles to
mark whatever events that you're
recording as conversion events.
So those conversion
events are things
that are especially
important for your app
and what you want to
direct your users to do.
So these could be things like,
did they create an account?
Did they invite your friend
to the game or their friend
to the game?
Did they give premium
currency to their games
or give something to their
friends for the game,
those kind of things.
Sorry.
I need go back to one slide.
And the other advantage
with marking these things
as conversion events, these
important things for your game,
is that Firebase
can use that to feed
that back to any ad campaigns
you have to attract more users.
And it'll tailor the
audiences that it
goes after there based
on the conversion data
that you care about.
So with Google, with
Google Cloud BigQuery,
and with Firebase
Analytics, you're
starting to get a picture.
You're starting to be able to
paint a picture, basically,
of what is going on in your
game and what your players are
doing.
So we answered the first
part of this question of,
how can I track how
my game is doing now?
And once you know that, you want
to look at the second part of,
now how can I easily
test new features
and see if those are good?
So typically, when you want
to test a new set of features,
you might have an
alpha or beta channel
where you'll release
that new set of features
and expose it to a test group.
And that's well and good but can
often have a lot of overhead.
For one, you have to match the
cadence of your team's release
cycle to get your build
available for each
of these channels.
And then, of course, you
need different build variants
that you deploy to
alpha or beta, which can
start becoming a bit of a pain.
Furthermore, if you're
releasing a new feature
and you want to easily get
feedback on it, if you're just
releasing it to
alpha or beta users,
you might not be
getting a large amount
of data versus
your whole audience
or at least a larger
percentage of your audience
where you're
getting the feedback
behind that new feature and
being able to determine--
and validate that it's working.
And then here's
another use case.
What if you want to just
release a temporary, seasonal,
or promotional new
feature in your game?
So in the case of
MechaHamster, let's say
we want to change the
color of the hamster ball
to white and red
just for Canada Day
when it's Canada
Day in that user's
device in the date/time
of that user's device
and for Canadian users.
Oh, sorry, I have
here one slide back.
So including that
one change, one
seasonal change or temporary
change into your build
can complicate that build
because you've already
got a few things planned.
And if you're using
this one new feature,
it can add some delay to that.
In addition to that, if
there's other higher priority
issues that come up for
your team's current build,
this might get dropped.
There might be other things
that they have to focus on.
And this is not really
something they can do.
And then you risk
losing it entirely.
So for both of those
use cases, when
you want to release
new features and easily
test them as well as for
seasonal changes you want
to introduce in
your game, there's
Firebase Remote Config
that we want to introduce.
So if you haven't
heard of this before,
you can think of it
as a key value pair
that-- a key value store
that lives in the Cloud.
And it allows you
to control the look
and feel of your game or
the behavior of your game
remotely without
having to rebuild
different versions of
your app and deploy it
to all the different
channels and app stores.
So this is the way it works.
Going back to our example for
the Canada Day hamster ball,
here's some default values
for what the hamster
ball looks like now.
So we've got ball_color,
ball_glow, and ball_size
as Remote Config parameters we
defined with these defaults.
So whenever the user starts up
the phone for the first time,
these are normally the
values that they'll
see for their ball.
Next, we introduce
some new values
for the ball, ball
color being white
and the ball glow being red.
And we can condition those
or gate them on specific--
any kind of conditions.
In this case, it
would be that it
is Canada Day on
the user's phone
on their date/time
on their device
and that they're
located in Canada.
For those users, we want
to push these values.
These will then be
waiting in the Cloud,
ready to replace the values
that we've set as the default.
And then when the condition
hits and everything is true,
it'll combine those
values, pulling the delta,
and then change the look of the
ball for those Canadian users.
Another cool thing about
the way Remote Config works
is that it only downloads
the delta, or the difference,
the diff of the values for
the Remote Config variables
and not the whole
set every time.
So you're not going to eat
up a lot of your user's data
by using Remote Config.
Now you might be
thinking, wait a minute.
Isn't this kind of like
feature rollout flagging?
And yeah, it is.
That's kind of the
idea behind it.
So it allows you to easily
control feature rollouts
for your game without having
to redeploy different builds
and enable and disable that
via the Firebase console.
One thing I should
mention actually
in the previous slide--
can I go two slides back?
Sorry.
So those new values
that you set,
you'd actually set those in
the Firebase console directly.
So you can do it through
the Firebase console.
Or you can do it
via the REST API.
So that's how you
can set and condition
the new values you
want to set on.
OK.
So we saw a little
bit of how to use
Remote Config for this
new seasonal feature
that we want to
release for Canada Day.
But how about like for
more general use cases?
There's some other times where
Remote Config can be helpful.
And more importantly, when
you're testing or releasing
these new features, you want to
get the feedback behind them.
So let's take a look at that.
OK.
So taking a look back
at the custom events
that I created for Google
Analytics for Firebase
for MechaHamster, if
you look at the ones
on the right-hand
side, I'm collecting
retries, whether the
user finished the level,
and what levels
they've selected.
Well, you could imagine that,
let's say a user who just
started playing this game, they
have a large number of retries
for a given level or they never
did manage to complete one
or they've only selected a
certain group of levels that
are fairly easy to complete.
You can imagine that those
are beginners to my game.
Well, one cool thing about the
way Remote Config and Analytics
works is that it allows you
to create different audiences
based on these custom
events you can filter or out
of the box events as
well in Analytics.
In this case, for
MechaHamster, I'm
creating a beginners audience.
And I want to target Remote
Config variables only
to that audience.
I'm defining that
as any players who
have a number of retries
recorded as greater than 5
and who haven't
completed a level.
So I've identified
this beginner audience.
And for them, I'm going to
change the values of my Remote
Config parameters
and set the ball
size to big and the gravity
to 0.5 to make the game easier
for them to play.
OK.
So that's cool, right?
I can easily release new things.
But what about different
variants that I want to try?
So for example, for
my beginner audience,
that new ball size
and gravity that I set
might make the game way too
easy for them and quite boring.
For cases where I want to
test multiple variations
or combinations of these
to see which one works best
for my beginner
audience, there's
Firebase A/B Testing
as well that works
in combination
with Remote Config
and Analytics for that purpose.
And here are the steps for
setting up A/B Testing.
So the first thing is
you define your target.
Whether that's 5% of
your total audience
or whether that's all your
users who speak Korean,
you can set that up
however you like.
For MechaHamster, that's going
to be the beginners audience
that I defined earlier.
Step two is you
create your variance.
So again, for MechaHamster, that
would be different combinations
of ball size and
gravity, so just
to see which combination works
best for this beginner group.
Step three is to determine
the goal for your A/B test.
So these can be out
of the box goals that
come from Analytics, things
like daily user engagement
and that kind of thing.
It can also be custom
events that you care about.
So what is the goal?
What are the things
that you want
to measure with these
different variants
to see if your experiment
is successful or not?
For MechaHamster,
that would probably
be that I want my daily
user engagement to increase,
I want the number of retries
to go down so that they're
having an easier time.
And I might add secondary goals.
For example, user retention
is a secondary goal
that I'd add here because I want
to make sure I'm not negatively
affecting the
retention of my game
among other beginners in
that group who might find
all those variants
boring and might
stop playing the game entirely.
So you can choose what goals you
want for your A/B test as well
and set those here.
And then the last step is
just to kind of wait and relax
and let the experiments
run for a couple of weeks
and start generating some
data that you can look at.
By the end of that, you'll
be able to determine
if there's one group that
performed extremely well
and then roll that
out as the new control
more broadly among your
beginner audience or whatever
other audience you define.
So thus far, we're using Remote
Config to release new features.
We're using A/B testing
to test different variants
and figure out
which one works best
and then roll that
out more broadly.
But this up to now has all
been reactive things we've
been doing for our players.
We've been seeing how
they behave so far
and then basically adding
new features based on what
we've seen at that point.
Wouldn't it be cool
if we could anticipate
what they're going
to do and, in fact,
if we could predict
the future and predict
how our users can behave
instead of reacting to it?
So if only there was someone
who could tell us our futures.
Well, there is.
And that's Firebase
Predictions, another product
available in Firebase.
So Firebase can
harness the power
of machine learning
to create groups
of users who are predicted to
exhibit some kind of behavior
in your app.
The general idea is that as your
players are playing your game,
Google Analytics is collecting a
bunch of data and storing that.
And then Predictions
can take a look
at that data to see if
there's any patterns that
exist for things that these
players have done before they
took some other desired action.
So let's say, for example,
that desired action is
a player who spent
money in your game
or made an in-app purchase.
What Predictions will
do is go ahead and look
at users who have
already made purchases
and look at the past data.
Then it will use a neural
network powered by TensorFlow
to see if there are any patterns
that these users have exhibited
before they made that purchase.
Once it does that,
it will start making
groups of users categorized
as likely spenders
or unlikely spenders.
And once those groups have
been identified by Predictions,
you can use those groups in
other features in Firebase.
And you can target
those predicted
users who are predicted
to spend in your game.
So whether that's in Remote
Config or in A/B tests,
you can now choose that
group and specifically
target different changes that
you want to roll out to just
them.
So let's look at a few examples
of different developers
who have done this.
Nope, we're going to look
at that later [LAUGHS]..
Can I go back one?
Can I go back one slide?
All right.
So how do you enable
this magic of machine
learning to your games?
Do you have to go back
to school and take
a neural network [INAUDIBLE]
programming class
and graduate from that again?
It might not hurt.
But you don't have
to do any of that.
You can actually just press this
button in the Firebase console.
So once you press this,
it turns Predictions on.
And from that point, it's
going to start collecting data.
And within a few
weeks, you should
have some Predictions data
that you can play with.
Now out of the box, the
two different events
that Predictions works
for is to determine
spenders and
nonspenders and also
users who might churn from
your app or continue using it.
But in addition to those, you
can use other custom events
that you care about
and use Predictions
to figure out if those actions
are likely to happen as well.
So those are those custom
events that I mentioned earlier
that you would mark
as conversion events
or things that are particularly
important for your game.
So you can mark those.
And then Predictions will start
training over that as well.
OK.
So here's where I was getting
to earlier about examples
of different game
publishers who have
used some combinations
of these features
to realize some
pretty good value.
So in this case,
there's Halfbrick.
What they did is that
they use Predictions
to determine churners,
people who are likely to stop
playing their game.
And in that group, they
targeted notifications
that gifted them premium
currency in their game.
And in doing so,
they saw a 20% boost
in seven-day user retention.
And it performed better
than a fixed reward system
that they had earlier.
There's also Rockbite.
So they used a combination of
predictions and Remote Config.
And in their case, they use the
groups that check for spenders.
And for those that were
determined to spend,
they changed the store layout
to better match their patterns.
And for those who are
determined to not spend,
they had a different layout
through the Remote Config
that they'd configured.
And in doing so, they
increased their profitability
and remain competitive
in an already competitive
mobile gaming industry.
OK.
So at this point,
let's say, you've
used analytics to
collect insights
into your data for
Google Cloud BigQuery
and upload your data
to slice and dice it.
You're using Remote
Config, A/B Testing
to test different variants.
And this is all great.
And let's say, as a result of
this, you've got a lot of users
and a lot of players.
And that's fantastic.
That's what you want.
But now you've
got a lot of data.
You've got a lot of
players and a lot of data
that you've
accumulated across all
of these different features.
So remember the image
of that data center
that I showed earlier when I
talked about a lot of features
and then I very sneakily
introduced BigQuery?
Well, here's another example
where BigQuery can help.
So Firebase and BigQuery
integrate really
easily with each other.
And you can export all
those different features
that I just mentioned,
so Analytics
data, Crashlytics data, as
well as Predictions data
into BigQuery
where you can slice
and dice it for other insights
that you want to gain.
So this is really
useful because there's
some things to these dashboards
themselves might not do
but that you could write your
own queries against to figure
out all kinds of things.
Here's some examples.
So for Analytics, if you
export your Analytics data
into BigQuery, you can
analyze user retention trends
for your game and identify
root causes behind them.
For Crashlytics, you can segment
crashes by levels, libraries,
or any other custom key that
you include in your crash logs.
So whatever custom
key you put in there,
once you've exported your
Crashlytics data into BigQuery,
you can now use that--
if you'd like to see, OK,
level 3 has an
issue, and level 3
is where most of these crashes
are happening-- fairly easily.
And then for Predictions,
one really straightforward
use case and a very common one
is to identify your biggest
spenders by city or by country
by running a query again
in BigQuery once you've
exported your data.
So this kind of wraps
up everything we
wanted to share with you guys.
We hope this helped you feel
excited about using Firebase
for your games.
We hope there's at
least one or two use
cases where you see that
you can use Firebase to help
in your game development.
And hopefully, you get
started and reach out to us
when you have any questions.
At the moment, I think we
still have some time for Q&A
if there's any live Q&A you
guys want to do in the room.
Otherwise, we'll be
just outside of here.
I think they're closing
down this room at 6:00.
So we'll be just
outside and hanging out
if you have any
questions for us.
But let's first, I
guess, open the room
and see if anyone
has any questions.
You guys want to return
back on the stage?
Any questions on using Firebase?
Going once, going twice.
No?
PATRICK MARTIN: Awesome!
We did our job.
[LAUGHTER]
CHEN LIENG: There's one.
AUDIENCE: I have [INAUDIBLE].
SUMIT CHANDEL: OK.
Oh, I think there's a
mic coming as well just
so other folks can hear ya.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Does the Unity plug-in natively
support Windows or just
iOS and Android right now?
SUMIT CHANDEL: I believe
that it's just Android--
Android and iOS, right?
CHEN LIENG: Yeah.
Right now, it's just
iOS and Android.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So if I wanted to use Windows,
I'd have to use the Wrap
the C++ SDK?
PATRICK MARTIN: I believe the
C++ SDK right now is an early
beta.
And not all of the
features are spec'd out.
It's good enough for you
to use in the Unity editor
or to test in desktop.
But we're still working on it.
And it is open-source now.
So if you go faster than
us, you can get there too.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SUMIT CHANDEL: All right.
If there are questions you
guys want to ask us in private,
we'll be just outside.
Also want to remind you guys
to scan your badges on the way
out just to make sure you get
the evaluation forms to give us
feedback on the talk.
And with that, thank you,
again, for participating.
Also if you want to download
MechaHamster and give it a try,
you can download it from
the App Store Play Store.
We also have all the code
hosted on GitHub there
if you want to download that,
build it, and check it out.
And to learn more about
how Firebase can help with
your game's development,
there is that URL right there,
firebase.google.com/games.
And we've got a booth.
And we're going to be
there most of the week.
It's in this building
at spot P1501.
I think it's in--
yeah, South Hall is here.
So we'll be there
all that week if you
want to come by and say hello.
All right.
Thank you very much.
CHEN LIENG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]